[Applaus]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live habt ihr in letzter Zeit versucht
in der Stadt eine Wohnung zu finden
Glück gehabt wer das nicht musste denn
freier bezahlbarer Wohnraum der wird in
Deutschland immer knapper rund 700.000
Wohnungen fehlen bei uns im Land um den
Bedarf zu decken die Tendenz ist
steigend das hat das Bündnis soziales
wohnen ausgerechnet das ist so viel wie
in 20 Jahren nicht mehr so ein Missstand
unser Thema also heute Wohnungsnot in
Deutschland und ihr könnt Fragen stellen
direkt im Stream kommentieren oder auch
per Mail ich habe auch ins Community Tab
schon mal reingeschaut bei uns wir
können mal zusammen schauen erste
Kommentare sind da Michael schreibt hier
in Wedel bei Hamburg ist es für mich
unmöglich eine größere Wohnung zu finden
die gibt es einfach keinen Wohnraum mehr
und kracht nach der oder die Userin
schreibt bei uns werden sich Häuser
aufgekauft die dann zu Profit Zwecken
renoviert werden die Mieten gehen hoch
und kaum einer kann sich das leisten
das also heute Thema bei uns und wir
können darüber sprechen mit der
Bundesministerin mit Klara galwitz von
der SPD sie ist verantwortlich für
Wohnen für bauen und für
Stadtentwicklung und heute bei uns zu
Gast schön guten Abend Frau Gallwitz die
Wirts hoffentlich auch bei uns sehen
genau schönen guten Abend
die Situation am Wohnungsmarkt ist
dramatisch das sagte der Präsident des
Deutschen Mieterbundes das Bautempo das
sei viel zu niedrig und ihre
Ampelkoalition die wollte 400.000 neue
Wohnungen bauen das war das Ziel im
letzten Jahr und das Bündnis soziales
wohnen sagt das sei klar verfehlt worden
was ist passiert oder besser gesagt was
es nicht passiert
ja ganz klar wir haben in Deutschland
seit vielen Jahren einen Problem bei der
Produktivität und das hat den letzten
Jahren dazu geführt dass unglaublich
viele Wohnungen genehmigt wurden aber
nicht gebaut wurden wir haben mal so ein
bauüberhang das sind diese genehmigten
Wohnungen von fast 850.000 Wohnungen das
passt fast in etwa mit dem
prognostizierten Bedarf aus ihrer Studie
und wir müssen einfach schneller und
mehr bauen das ist das eine und das
andere ist natürlich dass dieser
furchtbare Krieg den Wladimir Putin in
der Ukraine angefangen hat zum einen
natürlich eine ganz ganz große
Flüchtlingsbewegungen Gang gesetzt hat
eine große solidarische Leistung von
vielen Deutschen aber natürlich auch von
unseren Nachbarländern dass wir 100.000
von Ukrainern bei uns aufgenommen haben
aber das verschärft natürlich die
Situation zum einen aber die Sanktionen
die Zinssteigerung der Fachkräfte Mangel
und natürlich Lieferengpässe das haben
die Situation auf den Baustellen noch
mal zusätzlich belastet deswegen ist das
in der Tat 2023 ein sehr sehr sehr
schwieriges Jahr für die deutsche
Bauwirtschaft über die einzelnen
Probleme wollen wir auch gleich im
Detail sprechen aber schauen uns jetzt
erst zusammen einen Beitrag an über das
Problem Wohnungsnot in Deutschland in
all seinen Details von Thomas gonsor
viele Menschen in Deutschland sind in
Not in Wohnungsnot das sagt das Bündnis
soziales wohnen derzeit viel mehr als
700.000 Wohnungen so viele wie seit mehr
als 20 Jahren nicht mehr besonders
Mangel ist an sozial und bezahlbaren
Mietwohnungen und das obwohl die
Bundesregierung helfen wollte Ziel der
Ampel war im vergangenen Jahr 400.000
Wohnungen schaffen davon 100.000
Sozialwohnungen tatsächlich entstanden
aber laut letzten Berechnungen weniger
als 300.000 Wohnungen davon nur 20.000
für sozial Bedürftige
Gründe dafür
Fachkräftemangel steigende Baukosten
etwa wegen Rohstoffknappheit und
Bürokratie
unrealistisch sei also auch ein weiteres
Ziel der Regierung 400.000
Sozialwohnungen bis 2025 und bezahlbare
Unterkünfte werden wohl noch knapper
auch wegen der Zuwanderung allein im
vergangenen Jahr kamen 1,5 Millionen
Menschen nach Deutschland was also tun
das Bündnis fordert Kosten senken z.B
runter mit der Mehrwertsteuer für den
sozialen Wohnungsbau auf sieben Prozent
weniger Bürokratie und mehr finanzielle
Hilfen konkret ein 50 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen für Sozialwohnungen und
wie es heißt gegen die Not in
Deutschland die Wohnungsnot
wir haben jetzt gerade im Beitrag gehört
nur 20.000 Sozialwohnungen sind
entstanden die werden ja besonders
dringend gebraucht was ist da passiert
das ist ja weit entfernt von dem Ziel
dass man sich mal gesteckt hatte ja also
das hat mich auch sehr überrascht als
ich die Zahl heute gelesen habe habe mir
das dann noch mal angeguckt und ein
Stück weit unseriös natürlich auch von
der Studie das sind die Zahlen von 2021
das heißt die Zahlen der
Vorgängerregierung und die
Vorgängerregierung meinen Vorgänger
Horst Seehofer CSU als baumminister hat
sehr sehr wenig ausgegeben für den
sozialen Wohnungsbau und deswegen ist
ein bisschen unfair dass jetzt die
Zahlen von 21 ins Feld geführt werden wo
doch diese Bundesregierung ausgerechnet
den Schwerpunkt setzt auf die Förderung
des sozialen Wohnungsbaus 14,5
Milliarden eine Rekordsumme geht in
diesem Bereich alleine in diesem Jahr
sind es 2,5 Milliarden und wie viel
Sozialwohnungen damit im letzten Jahr
gebaut wurden 2022 das werden wir erst
in wenigen Monaten erfahren insofern
weiß ich die Zahl 20.000 ganz deutlich
zurück und zum zweiten ist so dass wir
eine zweite Säule der staatlichen
Finanzierung machen werden die
wohngemeinnützigkeit das sind Wohnungen
die dann dauerhaft preiswert sind und
auch dafür werden wir eine Förderung auf
den Weg bringen und dann ansonsten kann
ich zustimmen brauchen wir
verschlankungen wir brauchen
Digitalisierung Umbau wir brauchen
Vereinheitlichung von Bauvorschriften
und auf diesem Weg hat der Boden sich
mit den Ländern und vielen anderen
Partnern bereits geeinigt es gab ja aber
auch ganz konkrete Forderungen jetzt das
Bündnissystem ihrer Meinung nach helfen
würden die mir darauf mal ein nämlich
einmal Mehrwertsteuer für den sozialen
Wohnungsbau muss runter von 19 auf 7%
wird hier gefordert außerdem ein
Sondervermögen von 50 Milliarden Euro
für den sozialen Wohnungsbau was sagen
sie dazu würden ist das möglich also
Sondervermögen klingt ja immer so super
muss man wissen das sind aber einfach
Schulden und das ist dann Zuschuss der
gezahlt wird für den so normalen
Wohnungsbau und da bin ich sehr dafür
dass wir da die Finanzen Stärken haben
wir auch gemacht mit 14,5 Milliarden für
diesen Bereich wir gucken uns das gerne
an ob die baukostensteigerung ist jetzt
notwendig machen da noch ein Klecks
draufzulegen aber Geld alleine löst das
Problem nicht ganz wichtig letztes Jahr
sind fast 20 Milliarden in die
Neubauförderung gegangen und alle gehen
davon aus dass das nicht dazu geführt
hat dass die baukapazitäten sich
ausgeweitet haben das wesentlich mehr
als 300.000 Wohnungen entstanden sind
was passiert wenn man in einen
ausgelasteten Markt dann Geld rein gibt
es ganz klar die Preise steigen da sehen
wir alle das sollten wir nicht noch
weiter anheizen durch zusätzliches Geld
ohne Bedingung und deswegen gibt es eine
staatliche Förderung nur noch mit der
Bedingung dass anschließend die Mieterin
Mieter von diesem Geld auch profitieren
das ist auch so ein bisschen das Problem
bei der Förderung der Reduzierung der
Mehrwert steuern das kann man machen
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
dann anschließend auch tatsächlich
weitergereicht wird an die Mieterinnen
und Mieter und dass die das im
Portemonnaie auch spüren dass
der Projektentwickler weniger Steuern
gezahlt hat mir ist das lieber wir
machen das mit einem ordentlichen
Vertrag der kriegten Zuschuss und muss
dann hinterher aber auch eine niedrigen
Miete für 20 für 25 Jahre garantieren es
gibt Fragen schon direkt bei uns im
Stream und zwar eine Frage bei Youtube
wie genau will die Regierung denn den
Mangel beheben wenn das Bauen immer
teurer wird die Zinsen steigen und die
KfW-Förderung eingestellt sind also die
KfW-Förderung müssen ganz klassisches
Beispiel da wurde gefördert egal ob das
jetzt nur eine Wohnung ist oder ein
anderes Gebäude was nicht zum Wohnen da
ist es wurde der gleiche Betrag für
kleine und für große Wohnungen gezahlt
und es wurde auch gezahlt egal ob die
Miete hoch oder niedrig ist das ist aus
meiner Sicht keine sinnvolle staatliche
Förderung die den Mieterinnen und
Mietern zu Gute kommt und noch mal
letztes Jahr fast 20.000 Milliarden sind
geflossen ohne dass wir ein großartigen
Defekt davon sehen dass mehr hergestellt
wurde offenbar als vorher weil die
Kapazitäten ausgelastet waren und
deswegen müssen wir die Kapazitäten
stark steigern zum Beispiel werden wir
es schaffen dass man in Zukunft seine
Bauanträge digital einreichen kann das
ist eine ganz große Entlastung für die
Bauherren und wir müssen natürlich
fragen wenn ich darf was heißt Zukunft
weil ich glaube das interessiert viele
Digitalisierungen die es ja so noch
nicht gibt was heißt Zukunft jetzt ist
das ganz normal hat vielleicht gehört es
gibt das Online zugangsgesetz des Bundes
da sollen alle Verwaltungsleistungen
digitalisiert werden wir haben extrem
dafür geworben dass der Bauantrag zu den
Leistung gehört die ganz ganz dringend
und zu fördert digitalisiert werden wir
arbeiten mit dem Land
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern daran dass es
genau dieses Jahr passiert dass man
überall in Deutschland sein Bauantrag
auch digital einreichen kann das alleine
ist ein wichtiger Schritt aber es nicht
ausreichend wir müssen natürlich auch
anders bauen wenn man im Jahr 1992 auf
einer Baustelle war und im letzten Jahr
wird man feststellen die sehen immer
noch sehr sehr ähnlich aus das ist in
vielen Branchen in Deutschland nicht
mehr der Fall da war vor 30 Jahren die
Produktion in ganz andere und wir müssen
natürlich auch in der Bauindustrie
anders mit mehr Roboter mit mehr Technik
mit mehr
it arbeiten um einfach die Stückkosten
die Kosten pro Wohnung zu reduzieren und
deswegen pushen wir zum Beispiel dass
der jelle bauen das Bauen mit
Vorprodukten ganz eindeutig aber wir
haben ja jetzt diesen ganz akuten
Wohnungsmangel wir haben es gehört
700.000 die fehlen so viele wie seit 20
Jahren nicht mehr das klingt für mich
alles was sie da gerade vorschlagen noch
wirklich eher in weiter Zukunft was ganz
unmittelbar jetzt kann man all diesen
Menschen die verzweifelt ja nach einer
Wohnung suchen in was kann man den denn
jetzt sagen also die eine akut Hilfe die
wir jetzt ab 1.1 diesen Jahres in Kraft
gesetzt haben ist das Wohngeld plus das
ist eine deutliche Ausweitung der
Unterstützung für Mieterinnen und Mieter
immerhin 2,5 Millionen Haushalte mit 4
Millionen Menschen bekommen diese
Unterstützung die dafür sorgen wird dass
man durchschnittlich 370 € Unterstützung
hat damit man sich seine Wohnung leisten
kann das andere dass wir ein Programm
auf den Weg gebracht haben 500 Millionen
nur für junge Menschen das heißt für
Azubi wohnen und für Studentenwohnheime
damit die Länder mit diesem Geld dann
auch ganz schnell in diesem Jahr Azubi
Wohnheime und Studentenwohnheime bauen
können denn gerade junge Menschen die
häufig ein befristeten
Ausbildungsvertrag haben die haben sehr
sehr schwer sie sprechen die Studenten
an das ist natürlich gerade für die
Studierenden die also in den Städten in
den teuren Großstädten auf der Suche
sind nach einer Wohnung besonders prekär
wenn Sie zum Beispiel natürlich nur im
bafög-zuschuss haben und dann auch nur
Nebenjob neben dem Studium schaffen da
ist es besonders schwer eben Wohnraum zu
finden wir schauen einen Beitrag
sprechen dann gleich weiter holen uns
noch einen Gast dazu ein Beitrag von
Josua schwarz
wir haben ein Tonproblem habe ich
mitbekommen dass man eben jetzt in der
in dem Beitrag keinen Ton hört deswegen
würde ich vorschlagen dass ich mir kurz
die Fakten aus dem Beitrag raussuche und
die mal kurz mitgeben kleinen Moment und
zwar so also das was wir eben leider nur
ohne Ton sehen konnten sind wichtige
zahlen die uns natürlich gleich im
Gespräch helfen werden gib mir einen
kleinen Moment jetzt habe ich hier bei
mir auflegen also schauen wir auf das
Jahr 2021 da haben wir die Zahlen und
zwar kostete da ein WG-Zimmer
durchschnittlich 391
Büro das war in den deutschen
Hochschulstädten und 2022 stieg der
Mietpreis für ein WG-Zimmer aber auf
durchschnittlich 435 Euro an das ist
eine Steigerung von 11,4 Prozent also
ordentlich natürlich klar die großen
Städte sind die teuersten das sind
München Frankfurt Berlin bei allen drei
Städten reißen die 550 Euro Marke in
München liegt man inzwischen mit 700 €
pro Monat deutlich an der Spitze also
für Menschen die dort studieren
unfassbar wie man das bezahlen soll und
dann kommen die bafög-auszahlungen dazu
die Reichen in vielen Fällen eben nicht
um die Mietkosten zu decken ich habe es
in der Anmoderation auch schon gesagt
denn die Wohnkosten pauschale die stieg
im vergangenen Juli auf 360 € im Monat
da ist natürlich dann klar auch eine
riesen Diskrepanz in 59
Hochschulstandorten reicht das aber
nicht für die Miete also noch mehr als
in den großen Städten 64% aller
Studierenden sind davon betroffen und
wir haben jetzt auch stellvertretend
eine Studierende bei uns ist das Rahel
Schüssler sie ist im Vorstand im Freien
Zusammenschluss der Studierendenschaften
studiert Rechtswissenschaften in der Uni
Bonn hallo schönen guten Abend
jetzt höre ich auch Frau Schüssler nicht
ich bin nur ich das vielleicht schreibt
ihr es mir mal in die Kommentare oder
gibt es insgesamt ein Problem Frau
Gallwitz hört Frau Schüßler auch nicht
dann gibt's hier größere technische
Schwierigkeiten ich versuche es noch mal
Frau Schüssler können wir sie hören
ich kann sie auf jeden Fall hören
wunderbar und wir alle uns jetzt auch
ich habe sie gerade schon vorgestellt
und zwar sind sie von Berlin nach Bonn
gezogen um zu studieren wie ist die Lage
ganz aktuell für Studierende in Bonn
ja die Lage ist wie überall angespannt
wann ist natürlich eine
studierendenstadt und es sind gar nicht
die Großstädte die hohe Preise haben
natürlich die auch aber vor allem auch
die Studie Städte also Bonn aber auch
Tübingen Lüneburg haben vergleichsweise
für die Größe der Stadt eine hohe also
einen hohen Mietpreis
die warteplätze auf den Listen für die
studiewohnheime sind massiv überfüllt
also man wartet da mehrere Monate lang
und auch als ich 2017 was ja wirklich
schon ein paar Jahre her ist nach Bonn
gezogen bin hatte ich keine Chance auf
einen studienwohnheim Platz genau und
deshalb weiß man dann auf den freien
Markt aus und da war ja dann auch gerade
schon eben die Zahlen wie die
angestiegen sind genau und im
Durchschnitt bezahlen da jetzt 435 Euro
aber das ist halt nur der Durchschnitt
also viele liegen halt noch mal deutlich
drüber genau und auch in Bonn sind die
Weise im Schnitt um 70 Euro gestiegen
pro Monat und was sind das denn jetzt
unsere Wege getroffen ja
und was wären denn ihre Forderungen
welche Hilfen brauchen denn Studierende
was wären ihre Forderungen an die
Politik in dem Fall haben Sie die
Möglichkeit jetzt die an Frau Gallwitz
zu stellen
genau also zum einen das natürlich
Studierendenwohnheime weiter finanziert
werden und auch gefördert werden aber
das auch gesehen wird dass viele
Studierende einfach auf dem freien Markt
suchen
und da dann auch auf niedrige mieten
angewiesen sind das muss zum einen über
sozialen Wohnungsbau laufen aber da
stellt sich dann auch immer teilweise
eine Problematik mit dem
Wohnberechtigungsschein und ich glaube
da könnte man
nachbessern aber
billige mieten oder andersrum gesagt
wenn es Mangel an Wohnraum gibt dann
trifft es vor allem diejenigen die sich
nicht leisten können und das sind in dem
Fall Studierende auch
und wie würden Sie denen direkt helfen
Frau Gallwitz weil die Studierenden sind
jetzt teilweise in der Situation in
Nürnberg erlangen habe ich das gelesen
die finden einfach gar keine Zimmer es
ist quasi nicht möglich dann in den
studienstädten überhaupt ein Zimmer zu
kriegen also das eine ist mir ist ganz
wichtig dass das eine Problematik ist
die die Studierenden ganz stark betrifft
aber auch die Auszubildenden und die
Drohne immer so ein bisschen aus der
Augenwinkel zu gefallen weil wir haben
ja gerade gesehen bei der Studierenden
gibt es auch starke
Interessenvertretungen der Studierenden
die sich lautstark dafür einsetzen aber
es gibt natürlich auch mit dem
Studentenwerken starken Träger eine
Organisation für die Studentenheime das
ist bei den Auszubildenden nicht so
deswegen ist mir ganz wichtig dass wenn
wir über die Wohnsituation von
Studierenden sprechen dass wir die
Azubis nicht vergessen weil denen geht's
ganz genauso gleich schwierig was die
Studierenden anbelangt so hatte ich
Bettina stark Watzinger die
Bundesbildungsministerin sehr intensiv
dafür eingesetzt dass die Studenten von
den ganzen entlastungspaketen des
letzten Jahres dass Sie davon
profitieren das war gleich Anfang
letzten Jahres der einmalige
Heizkostenzuschuss der dann auch noch
mal zu einem zu einem zweiten
Heizkostenzuschuss erhöht wurde und auch
noch mal einer extra pauschale wo gerade
jetzt die Debatte läuft wie die denn an
die Studierenden kommt quasi als
individuelle Unterstützung für jeden
einzelnen Studierenden und das zweite
ist wir brauchen einfach mehr
studentenwohnheimplätze wir brauchen
mehr azubiwohnheimplätze und zwar in
ganz unterschiedlicher Zusammensetzung
und wir haben uns intensiv auch
ausgetauscht zum Beispiel mit dem
Studentenwerk weil heutzutage ist die
Lebenswirklichkeit von Studierenden
anders als die von mir in meinem Studium
es passiert sehr viel mehr online die
Studierenden brauchen auch sehr viel
mehr Platz in ihren Studentenwohnheim
für das Online-Studium weil sie
natürlich nicht mehr die ganze Zeit
Präsenz
Veranstaltung haben das muss man bei der
Architektur
Studentenheime berücksichtigen genauso
wie unser Anspruch auf Barrierefreiheit
für moderne
Studentenwohnheime und deswegen haben
wir gesagt wir geben das erste Mal einen
extra Programm an die Länder 500
Millionen in diesem Jahr und mit diesem
Programm können bestehende Wohnheime
modernisiert werden in etwa zum Beispiel
zum Ausbau der Barrierefreiheit damit
wirklich auch jeder Student in
Deutschland Zugang hat zur preiswerten
Studentenwohnheim und mit diesem Geld
können natürlich auch einzelne Wohnungen
mit der Belegung eingekauft werden oder
aber ganze neue Studenten und Azubi
Wohnheime gemacht werden und ich sage
auch ganz deutlich wenn dieses Programm
diese 500 Millionen dieses Jahr gut
abschließen wenn das Programm gut
angenommen wird von den Bundesländern
dann bin ich auch bereit das im nächsten
Jahr vorzuführen das wäre dann insgesamt
1 Milliarde die wir für diesen Bereich
ganz speziell für die jungen Menschen in
unserem Land und für Ihre Wohnung dann
zur Verfügung stellen
etwas was Rahel Schüssler und viele
Studierende natürlich besonders
interessiert dass das zeitnah passiert
dann sage ich vielen Dank Frau Schüssler
dass Sie bei uns zu Gast waren Frau
geibels bleibt noch bei uns und wir
reden noch einen Moment weiter denn es
gibt natürlich noch weitere Themen
gerade im Bereich bauen über die wir
auch noch mal sprechen wollen und auch
noch über weitere Themen im Bereich
mieten denn wer denn tatsächlich Glück
hat eine Wohnung zu finden der kann sich
ja nicht darauf verlassen dass er da für
ewig wohnen bleiben darf haben viele
schon schmerzlich erlebt oder auch noch
nicht mal nur eine kurze Zeit bleiben
darf denn manche Immobilienunternehmen
versuchen mit allen Mitteln Mieterinnen
und Mieter loszuwerden wenn es schlecht
läuft dann kann einem das so gehen damit
sie eben die Wohnung modernisieren
können teurer machen können und einer
der das erlebt hat dass es wenn Fischer
aus Berlin vor zehn Jahren bekamen alle
Mieter in seinem Haus im Prenzlauer Berg
die Kündigung auf den Tisch er war der
Einzige der blieb der das ausgehalten
hat und der vor Gericht gezogen ist und
sich gewehrt hat er hat sogar
tatsächlich gewonnen und seine Interesse
haben sogar zu Gesetzesänderungen
geführt Luxus Sanierungen zum Zweck der
Entmietung sind mittlerweile eine
Ordnungswidrigkeit hallo schönen guten
Abend herr Fischer sie sind jetzt
nämlich auch live bei uns hallo schönen
guten Abend heißt das Herr Fischer sie
haben den Prozess ja gewonnen sie dürfen
jetzt bleiben alles ist gut naja den
Prozess ist erstmal also wir waren ja
mehr als 50 Prozesse und sechs Jahre
wirklich ein Fulltime-Job um am Ende mit
meiner Familie meinen Kindern dort in
der Wohnung zu bleiben also das war
schon sehr harter Weg und wir sind den
aber gegangen um einfach da auch
wirklich sehr öffentlichkeits- und
Politik wird wirksam in Erscheinung zu
treten und wirklich vielen Menschen die
nicht diese Kraft und die Ressourcen
haben diesen Weg zu gehen auch eine
Stimme zu geben und vor allen Dingen
wirklich in der Politik da die
Alarmglocken zu Leuten und zu sagen
warte mal hier geht was richtig schief
Frau Gallwitz würden Sie denn sagen der
Staat der müsste härter eingreifen und
regulieren um eben Menschen vor so etwas
zu schützen also wir haben uns ja
vorgenommen in der Koalition zwei Sachen
mindestens zu machen das ist eine dass
die mietpreisbremse verlängert wird das
andere ist dass die Kappungsgrenze das
klingt jetzt sehr technisch aber das ist
sozusagen die Frage wie viel Geld darf
man auf die Miete raufschlagen wenn man
zum Beispiel saniert dass das auch
reduziert wird und gerne das nicht
eintreten zu lassen was bei Herrn
Fischer passiert ist und das sind
Verabredungen des mietrechtes die muss
der Kollege Buschmann Umsetzen der
Justizminister der für Mietrecht
zuständig ist da warte ich jetzt schon
eine geraume Zeit sehnsüchtig und nicht
nur ich sondern viele Mieterinnen und
Mieter und ich hoffe dass das bald auch
passiert im Justizministerium und wir
sehen natürlich auch noch weitere Punkte
zum Beispiel bei Index mieten die
gekoppelt sind an die allgemeine
Preisentwicklung und das ist für die
Mieterin zur Zeit bei dem jetzigen
Preisentwicklung sehr sehr schwierig das
andere ist das eine ist das Mietrecht
das andere ist tatsächlich dann wie die
Mieterinnen und Mieter auch in der Lage
sind sich zu wehren herr Fischer hat
einen sehr sehr langen sehr
anstrengenden Kampf hinter sich und das
schaffen nicht alle und deswegen ist es
auch wichtig dass wir natürlich eine
gesunde Mieterstruktur haben dass wir
auch viele
genossenschaftliche MieterInnen zum
Beispiel haben viele starke
Genossenschaften viele kommunale
Wohnungsanbieter damit wir auch einen
entspannten Wohnungsmarkt bekommen und
wir auch natürlich sehr sehr viele
sozial engagierte private Vermieter
haben das weiß ich auch aber es gibt
natürlich auch schwarze Schafe und je
besser der Mix ist von unterschiedlichen
Vermietern desto größer ist natürlich
auch ähm die Macht des einzelnen Mieter
sich durchzusetzen im Zweifelsfall auch
gegen solche schwarzen Schafe wie das
Bayern Fischer der Fall war von einem
entspannten Wohnungsmarkt den sie gerade
angesprochen haben sind wir natürlich
jetzt irgendwie noch Kilometer weit
entfernt vor allem in Berlin denn
typischer wo würden Sie denn jetzt hin
wenn sie raus müssen sie sind in
Berliner gibt es für sie überhaupt
Möglichkeiten in Berlin noch mal was zu
finden haben sie da mal geschaut ja also
so schön formuliert also jeder kann
irgendwie der nach Berlin kommt in sein
Zuhause zurück mein Zuhause ist hier ich
weiß dann nicht wo ich hingehen soll
auch mit meinen Kindern die sind hier in
Prenzlauer Berg in Berlin geboren und
inne Sachen doch ohne Frau geibitz da
persönlich an greifen zu wollen diese
also den Skripte kommt mir bekannt vor
ich hatte ja damals auch vor zehn Jahren
treffen damals mit Heiko Maas als
Bundesjustizminister und ich habe die
gleiche vor 10 Jahren gehört also da hat
sich wirklich nichts geändert und die
Situation für die Mieter und MieterInnen
sind ist in den letzten zehn Jahren noch
viel prekärer geworden also diese
Statements der Politik entschuldigen sie
bitte ich kann es einfach nicht mehr
hören und das in den letzten Jahren
passiert ist wo wir immer für eine
treten sind sozusagen ihr müsst die
Wohnung im Bestand schützen ihr müsst
einfach dafür sorgen dass die Mieter
nicht aus ihren Wohnungen rausgeprügelt
werden können und dann könnt ihr neu
bauen und dann können wir eventuell
irgendwie das schaffen dass der mit dem
Markt nicht kollabiert das ist einfach
nicht gehört worden da wurde einfach
nicht genügend getan und deshalb also
kann die kann es einfach nicht mehr
hören und Frau Gallwitz was würden Sie
dann nämlich sagen also ganz
unmittelbare Hilfe herr Fischer hat es
angesprochen das hat sich nichts getan
sie sind ja jetzt am Zug haben die
Chance was zu ändern was was wie
unmittelbar Mieterinnen und Mieter denn
schützen also auch wenn Herr Fischer das
jetzt eine doofe Antwort findet für das
Mietrecht ist nun mal die bauministerin
nicht zuständig sondern der
Justizminister der ist jetzt dabei und
aufgefordert die Verabredung zu machen
z.B die Verlängerung der mietpreisbremse
oder die Kappungsgrenze noch weiter nach
unten zu setzen und natürlich werden wir
erst dann Entspannung sehen wenn Angebot
und Nachfrage einigermaßen Gleichklang
sind und das heißt natürlich dass wir in
Berlin auch mehr bauen müssen als bisher
weil die Stadt sehr sehr attraktiv ist
das finden wir alle schön an Berlin aber
das ist natürlich nicht mehr so wie in
den 90ern wo man ziemlich viel Leerstand
hat wo man Beispiel unsanierte Wohnung
hatte sondern jetzt sind viele
zusätzliche Menschen in die Stadt
gekommen und daraus muss man den Schluss
ziehen dass man auch in Berlin
zusätzlich bauen muss
das sind wahrscheinlich jetzt zunächst
mal keine so befriedigen befriedigenden
Antworten für Sven Fischer aus Berlin
aber wir danken sehr dass sie noch mal
kurz ihre Lage geschildert haben im
dieser in dieser Situation in Berlin die
wirklich nicht einfach ist vielen Dank
dass Sie bei uns zu Gast waren sehr
gerne Frau Gallwitz sie noch für einen
Moment kurz bei uns für eine Frage genau
herr Fischer haben wir verabschiedet
denn wir wollen noch mal ganz kurz zum
Bauen sprechen kommen jetzt aber auch
zum Ende denn viele können sich ja bauen
wirklich nicht mehr leisten wir haben
nachgefragt bei Markus Becker er ist
Geschäftsführer bei Condor Wessels einem
der größten Bauplaner in Berlin
beschreibt dass seine neuen Aufträge
quasi zum Erliegen gekommen sind und
geht auch noch mal gezielt auf die
Problematik des sozialen Wohnungsbaus
ein wir haben einen Ton von ihm hören
kurz rein und können dann zum Schluss
noch mal drüber sprechen
mein Kräuter auf einem Grundstück ein
Haus bauen will dann muss ich um die
Kosten für den Neubau wieder
reinzukriegen diesen Neubau eigentlich
für 10 bis 12 Euro pro Quadratmeter
vermieten wenn ich einigermaßen
günstiges Grundstück kaufe und wenn die
Stadt versucht für 6,85 Euro oder die
öffentliche Hand die hier in Berlin
solche Mieten zu erzielen dann ist das
mit dem Neubau nicht machbar es sei denn
wenn wir Quoten kriegen um die 30%
sozial mieten darzustellen also wir
müssen in wenn wir 100 neue Wohnungen
bauen da müssen wir 30% davon für 6,50 €
6,60 € vermieten
und wenn ich machen muss Musik die
anderen 70 Prozent Wohnung für jenseits
von 14 oder 15 Euro vermieten damit es
wirtschaftlich irgendwie tragbar ist und
damit wird diese mittlere Marktsegment
also eine 75 Quadratmeter Wohnung für
750 oder 800 Euro zu vermieten nie mehr
möglich sein in diesen Städten wird also
die die hohen Mieten werden damit immer
weiter in die Höhe getrieben
also kurz zusammengefasst Wohnen für
mittleres Einkommen wird nie mehr
möglich sein dann in diesen Städten wie
wollen Sie diesen Problemen begegnen
also ganz ehrlich Herr Bäcker hat gesagt
er kann für zehn Euro Neubau machen das
ist etwas was wo ganz viele
Bauunternehmer als aufgehört haben und
dann gesagt müssen wir mal bei Herrn
Bäcker anrufen wie der das in Berlin
schafft er hat sich ja im Prinzip
darüber beschwert und hat gesagt ich
kann also normalerweise für 10 bis 12 €
machen aber die Berliner sagen mir ich
muss 30 bin von meinen Wohnungen die ich
da bau Sozialwohnungen machen für unter
7 Euro und dann werden die anderen
teurer das geht dann im Schnitt aber bei
10 12 Euro raus das hat er ja selber
gesagt was gar kein schlechter Preis
wäre das würden viele in Berlin gerne
bei Herrn Becker mieten
wir haben noch Fragen aus unserer
Community und zwar möchte Robert es
gerne Wissen zum Thema Neubau eben wird
der Neubau wieder gefördert und wenn ja
zu welchen Auflagen
wir haben eine ganz unterschiedliche
Neubauförderung das eine ist der soziale
Wohnungsbau das sind 14,5 Milliarden die
wir ausgeben für diesen Bereich wir
haben erstmalig eine Förderung wenn man
eine Genossenschaft gründet oder
Genossenschaftsanteil erwerben will wir
werden dieses Jahr starten eine
Förderung von Familien mit Kindern die
wenig verdienen und sich ein Eigenheim
zulegen wollen und wir haben auch einen
kleinen Bereich an allgemeiner Förderung
von mehr Familienhäusern die dann
bestimmten ökologischen Kriterien
entsprechen aber grundsätzlich bin ich
der Meinung dass wir es nicht schaffen
können dass wir einen allgemeinen
Baukostenzuschuss finanzieren sondern
wir müssen uns so anstrengen produktiver
werden digitaler werden mit mehr Robotik
und mit mehr vor Produktion dass man
auch nicht subventioniert preiswert
bauen kann
und zum Schluss die letzte Frage
wirklich aus dem Stream wir könnten noch
ewig reden aber irgendwann muss dieser
Stream dann auch leider enden aber hier
ist ein Kommentar der ist noch sehr
interessant von Linda sie schreibt ich
würde mir wünschen dass die ganzen
bundeseigenen Wohnungen mal ordentlich
saniert werden und nicht nur neue Häuser
gebaut werden viele Immobilien sind
einfach unbewohnt und vergammeln weil
sich niemand kümmert also dieser
Leerstand den es ja auch gibt dieser
teilweise auch gezielte provozierte
Leerstand dagegen muss ja auch etwas
getan werden was haben sie da ganz
konkret vor ja das ist eine sehr
interessante Frage weil sie genau klar
macht dass diese Bundesregierung sich
von ihrer Vorgänger Regierung
unterscheidet die bundeseigenen
Wohnungen die waren in den vergangenen
Jahren vor allen Dingen eine cash-kau
die wurden verkauft die meisten
Grundstücke des Bundes wurden auch
verkauft zu Höchstpreisen damit der
Finanzminister eine ordentliche
Einnahmequelle hat und wir haben jetzt
gesagt wir haben damit auf wir geben zum
Beispiel preiswert bundesgrundstücke an
die Kommunen damit die da Schulen bauen
können oder halt auch auch preiswerte
Wohnung und wir fangen wieder an in
unseren eigenen Wohnungsbestand zu
investieren die zuständige Bundes GmbH
die Beamer die es dabei ein großes
Sanierungsprogramm zu machen damit es
aufhört dass die bundeswohnung
leerstehenden schlechten Zustand sind
sondern dass wir hier auch eigene
Bundeswohnungen anbieten können und ich
weiß dass auch viele Kommunen aber auch
einige Länder sich jetzt auch auf den
Weg machen verstärkt wieder selber
Landes- oder kommunalgesellschaften
gründen um selber wieder staatlichen
Wohnungsbau zu machen
danke für Ihre Zeit heute für ihre
Antworten Klara geil wird sie haben
viele vieles versprochen vieles dass ich
ändern soll bei 700.000 fehlenden
Wohnungen im Land ist es auf jeden Fall
wichtig und auch Zeit wir freuen uns
natürlich dass sie wieder wenn sie
wiederkommen und wir dann auch darüber
sprechen können hoffentlich zeitnah was
ich getan hat lieben Dank dass sie da
waren bundesbauministerin klareritz sehr
gerne und bis bald
und bei euch in den Kommentaren habe ich
auch noch mal einen Blick drauf geworfen
möchte also mit einem Kommentar Enden
von Michael Moritz Max bei Facebook der
schreibt dass es wirklich traurig das
Studenten oder Familien mit Kindern
keine passende Wohnung finden auch
Arbeitslose werden stark benachteiligt
da muss ich was ändern ja da muss ich
was ändern und wir bleiben für euch dran
für heute erstmal danke schönen Abend
und tschüss